joe biden's announcement of kamala
harris as vp
well it contained a telling tidbit
this is what he said in the written
statement i've decided that kamala
harris is the best person to help me
take this fight to donald trump
and mike pence and then to lead
this nation starting in january 2021
wait wait
to lead this nation wait was it wasn't
that you
supposed to be on the top of the ticket
doing all that leading for us joe
you know that whole presidency thing
come on man
even joe's with it enough to understand
that he's not really going to be running
the show
if he wins in november it has to be
demonstrated that
whomever i pick is two things one
is capable of immediately being
president because i'm an old guy
okay no but i'm serious
well now that we know who will really be
taking the reins and obama
administration
let's take a look at what she'll do if
they're elected
today the new york times went the absurd
route of touting the senator
as a quote moderate of course the
opposite is
the case for starters her position on
illegal
border crossings i believe if someone
crosses over the border it's
illegally it is illegal and you would
you would decriminalize it i would
not make it a crime punishable by jail
of course not come on in bienvenidos
and what about taxpayer-funded health
care for all those new undocumented
democrats
raise your hand if govern if your
government plan would provide coverage
for undocumented
immigrants
don't you love the hand raised questions
i love those
what about abortion i'm going to put in
place and require
that states that have a history
of passing legislation that is designed
to to prevent or or limit a woman's
access to reproductive health care
that those laws have to come before my
department of justice for a review
that's called pre-clearance that means
partial birth abortion
greenlit under president harris
and she loves socialized medicine
do you think eliminating private
insurance would be a socialist idea
no okay so my um i strongly believe that
we need to have medicare for all
do you think that's socialist or not
medicare for all no no
it's about providing health care to all
people
yeah yeah it's worked out well for
california everything they're trying out
there
and did i mention that kamala also wants
to take your guns away
upon being elected i will give the
united states
congress 100 days to get their act
together and have the courage
to pass reasonable gun safety laws and
if they fail to do it
then i will take executive action
no reasonable gun safety a little
commonology needed there
here come the guns the times also by the
way called her pragmatic
we say that's fraudulent tulsi gabbard
exposed kamala as a phony
on criminal justice senator harris says
she's proud of her record
as a prosecutor and that she'll be a
prosecutor president she put over 1500
people in jail for marijuana violations
and then laughed about it when she was
asked if she ever smoked marijuana and i
am proud
of making a decision to not just give
fancy speeches
or be in a legislative body and give
speeches on the floor
the people who suffered under your reign
as prosecutor oh
you owe them an apology
tulsi gabbard just took her apart do you
remember that debate
now furthermore senator harris basically
accused joe biden of being a racist on
national tv
it was hurtful to hear you
talk about the reputations of two
united states senators who built their
reputations
and career on the segregation of race
you also worked with them to oppose
bussing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bussed to school every day
and that little girl was me
that was the it moment well after that
she very publicly suggested that biden
was guilty of
sexually assaulting tara reid
somebody who has a relationship with
vice president biden
what message would you give to the women
who feel like their space has been
invaded and passed by the vice president
i believe them
and i i respect them being able to tell
their story and having the courage to do
it
do you believe that the vice president
should enter this race
he's gonna have to make that decision
for himself
marinate in all that for a moment okay
essentially
racist at least in pro you know
promoting all these past senators like
robert byrd friendship so
and implicitly at the very least
implicit
she was saying he was guilty of sexual
assault but now all of a sudden she's
willing to work with him
a segregationist and a sex criminal
well it's a good question maybe somebody
in the lame stream media
will have the courage to ask about this
but given all these issues i've no doubt
that the biden campaign looked far and
wide
for a better option than harris but i
guess there wasn't
wasn't anyone susan rice had way too
much baggage and no election experience
former obama advisor david axelrod said
tonight biden
actually clicked best with governor
whitmer
but she's not a woman of color and runs
michigan like a tin pot dictatorship
and the other candidates were political
small fries without any type of
experience or name recognition
that you'd want in a vp of course
biden's big mistake of course was
narrowing his options by limiting his
choice on the basis of skin color
and on planet earth that used to be
called bias or even racism
using color as a metric well that's what
he decided to do
and as someone running for the nation's
highest office biden is
morally obligated to pick the best
person to take his place
in the event of a tragedy regardless of
race or gender of ethnicity any of it
but he never even tried to do that how
cynical
instead he viewed the whole thing as a
box checking exercise
for the woke crowd he should have made
his choice
just on merit but now he's stuck with
harris
the bottom line she ran for president
not so long ago
and had a golden opportunity to present
herself to liberal voters in the
democrat party
but they rejected her in the most
comprehensive manner possible
making it absolutely clear that they
didn't regard her as worthy of serving
as president
now in a desperate effort to please the
hard left
biden has rejected the judgment of his
own party's voters
and placed harris in line to have all
the power
that democrats thought she shouldn't
have